also breaking overnight in Michigan a
manhunt has ended for a suspected
shooter and a campus killing 19 year-old
James Eric Davis was taken into custody
in the city of Mount Pleasant more than
a hundred police officers spent Friday
searching neighborhoods around Central
Michigan University for Davis after his
parents were found shot to death in a
campus dorm room DeMarco Morgan is here
with the latest
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
the suspect was spotted by someone under
train as it passed through the Central
Michigan campus he was arrested a short
time later and the shooting happened on
the last day of classes at the school
before a week-long break as many parents
were arriving to pick up their kids the
CMU Police Department is responding to a
report of shots fired the shooting
inside a dorm room shook Central
Michigan University with a campus on
lockdown students were encouraged to
shelter in place so right now what I'm
seeing is a lot of paramedics police
officers FBI is on scene right now I
spoke with one of my sources that's
actually on the fourth floor of Campbell
Hall where those shots rang out and
she's very shooken up she's telling me
that right now no police officers are
checking Hall by hall room by room the
incident took place on the last day of
classes before Spring Break with parents
on campus picking up children we believe
the situation involves a domestic type
incident University Police identified
the victims as James Davis a police
officer and his wife Deva their son
James Eric Davis jr. is the only suspect
in their killings and we're asking that
our community members call us call 911
if you see this individual and he should
be considered armed and dangerous
SWAT teams looked for Davis by foot
while helicopter searched for any signs
of Davis by air students who know Davis
say they are in shock it took my breath
away I would never expect it to be him
at all he was normal and he was funny I
never would have guessed he was a good
kid police say the younger Davis was
hospitalized a Thursday night because of
a possible drug overdose in addition to
being a police officer James Davis Singh
was an Iraq war veteran and friends say
the suspects mother was a breast cancer
survivor just an awful and disturbing
story incredibly sad DeMarco incredibly
said thank you